risque pas de démobiliser les Français
en disant finalement on fait tout ça
pour rien le gouvernement ne bougera pas
je pense que non parce que on voit
qu'elle sera certainement peut-être même
encore plus forte puisque depuis le
début de l'annonce de cette réforme il y
a de plus en plus de Français qui sont
contre on est après de 72 % à peu près
des Français qui qui sont opposés et on
a vu par le passé que c'est justement
dans la rue que ce gagnera
principalement le combat contre cette
réforme des retraites en raison de cet
accord avec LR et les Français ont bien
conscience qu'ils ont un petit peu leur
destin entre leurs mains s'ils veulent
que cette réforme échoue il faut que la
mobilisation soit la plus forte possible
pour que le gouvernement recule oui vous
entendez la détermination d'Elisabeth
borde vous pensez vraiment pouvoir faire
reculer le gouvernement je pense que oui
tout à fait on ne peut pas faire des
réformes contre le franc contre les
Français à partir du moment où les
Français et contrairement à ce que dit
Emmanuel Macron est-ce que dit Elisabeth
borne le gouvernement n'a pas mandat
pour cette pour cette réforme c'est pour
ça que d'ailleurs avec les députés à
l'Assemblée nationale nupes il y a une
proposition de référendum on leur dit
très bien chiche faites un référendum
demander aux Français s'ils sont
d'accord ou non avec cette réforme pour
pouvoir la faire donc cette réforme
qu'est-ce que vous allez poser comme
comme question dans le référendum elle
est pas si complexe que ça parce que il
y a pas que le report de l'année quelle
que soit les mesures à partir du moment
le socle qui est basé sur tout les
mesures toutes les récences sont sur un
sort profondément injustes qui est
justement l'augmentation de l'âge de 62
64 vous pouvez faire après toutes les
aménagements à la marge en dessous ça
reste profondément injuste et ce qui
cristallise justement l'opposition des
Français c'est cette mesure d'âge de 62
à 64 ans donc c'est ça qu'il faut sur
laquelle il faut revenir après qu'on
aménage qu'on favorise qu'on qu'on
améliore le dispositif nous nous sommes
favorables pour améliorer justement
notre système de retraite pour le rendre
beaucoup plus juste qu'il est encore
plus juste qu'il est actuellement on va
revenir sur sur le fond et sur ce que ce
que vous souhaitez faire sur le fond du
texte mais sur cette phrase de Gérald
Darmanin la nuque ne cherche qu'à
aborder le pays quand dites-vous alors
très c'est pas la nups qui mobilise qui
est immobilisé dans la rue ce sont les
Français donc en fait ce qui bordélise
le pays c'est cette réforme et si
Monsieur Darmanin qui est un peu
quelqu'un d'assez violent puisque ce
gouvernement ce qui propose c'est
quelque chose de très brutal les
Français sont épuisés nous avons eu la
pandémie nous sommes dans une crise
inflationniste les Français ont du mal à
joindre les déboux c'est comme si il se
prenait un nouveau coup sur la tête avec
ce autre cette réforme en disant bon bah
là ils sont ils sont à terre donc on va
en profiter pour leur passer des choses
inacceptables je pense que c'est ça qui
est très brutal pour nos compatriotes
sur le fond parce qu'on entend un peu de
son de cloche au PS est-ce que vous vous
êtes pour le maintien de la retraite à
62 ans pour un retour à 60 ans Alors moi
je serais plutôt favorable effectivement
pour les 60 ans mais je n'irai même plus
loin que ça je pense qu'il faut qu'on
réfléchisse parce que la principale
inégalité que met en exergue finalement
ce débat j'ai regardé les chiffres les
5% les plus aisés ont une espérance de
vie à peu près jusqu'à 84 ans les 5% les
plus pauvres 71 ans pour moi la vraie
injustice elle est là c'est pratiquement
très en écart ce qu'il faudrait c'est
penser un système de retraite ou
partirez même encore plus tôt les
ouvriers et les employés ça pourrait
être à 55 ans et les cadres et les
professions intellectuelles qui ont une
espérance de vie plus longue
éventuellement à 65 ans 66 ans je pense
que il faut prendre en compte du début
de carrière mais en fonction de la
pénibilité de votre métier qu'on décide
de l'âge de départ à l'heure actuelle ce
sont les gens les plus démunis quand les
métiers les plus pénibles et qui ont
l'espérance de vie les plus faibles qui
payent justement pour les cadres pour
les professions supérieures et ça c'est
profédant profondément injuste j'ai fait
ce petit calcul en faisant cette réforme
55 ans ça permettrait aux ouvriers de
vivre 16 ans à la retraite et malgré que
ça soit repoussé pour les employés les
professionnels il pourrait quand même
vivre plus longtemps puisque ça serait
19 ans je pense que ça ça serait
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus juste et on
prend réellement en compte l'espérance
de vie des gens c'est
un avantagé par votre groupe alors c'est
pas partagé forcément par tout le monde
mais comme je vous dis c'est quelque
chose qui est mis dans le débat je sais
qu'il y a certains députés socialistes
qui l'ont proposé comme Philippe Brun
qui a un nouveau député à l'Assemblée
nationale moi j'y suis en tout cas
favorable pour qu'on puisse réfléchir
nous-mêmes sur des contre-propositions
de ce type là sur cette question de la
pénibilité Gérald Darmanin encore un qui
a donné une grande interview hier au
Parisien Aujourd'hui en France il
dénonce
lipocyte qui n'a jamais réglé les cas
comme ceux de sa mère qui est femme de
ménage qui doit partir à plus de 67 ans
parce qu'elle a une carrière hachée qui
ne s'est jamais intéressée aux retraites
minimum qu'est-ce que vous dites de ça
alors après il faut pas dire n'importe
quoi sur l'histoire des retraites
minimum parce que ce qu'on entend
partout 1200 euros il faut savoir que
par rapport aux petites retraites ça ne
concernera que un tiers des personnes
qui ont une petite retraite puisque la
plupart du temps justement il faut
pouvoir avoir fait les 43 annuités ce
qu'on des petites retraites c'est pas
pour rien c'est parce qu'elles ont
souvent des carrières hachées qui ne
leur permettent pas d'aboutir aux fameux
40 futurs 43 ans pour pour dire que là
le gouvernement est en train de faire ce
que la gauche n'a pas fait quand elle
était au pouvoir non pas spécialement
puisque comme je vous dis ça concerne
très peu de personnes c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment dur par contre je suis
d'accord qu'il faut qu'il faut faire
attention et de permettre à des
personnes d'avoir un minimum vital à la
retraite c'est en ça que c'est pas
suffisant puisque comme je vous l'ai dit
ça ne couvre que 33% des personnes qui
sont concernées un dernier mot là-dessus
puisque les républicains eux ont déposé
à l'A un amendement qui dit que pour
toute personne qui a commencé à
travailler avant 21 ans ce sont les 43
annuités qui doivent être prises en
compte et n'ont pas l'âge légal de
départ c'est quelque chose que vous
pourriez soutenir par contre nous de
toute façon c'est très dur de dire de
soutenir on est contre la réforme on ne
la soutiendra pas on va s'opposer on va
on va mener la bataille à l'Assemblée et
au Sénat contre cette réforme finalement
on va être la chambre déco de ce qui se
passe dans la rue pour que vu que le
gouvernement ne veut pas entendre ben
nous on va on va essayer de faire
entendre ce qui se passe dans la rue
dans l'hémicycle il y a un autre texte
que vous allez examiner dans les
prochaines semaines et qui arrive
mercredi en Conseil des ministres c'est
le projet de loi immigration porté à la
fois par Gérald Darmanin et par Olivier
du socle ministre du Travail alors que
contient ce texte réponse avec Alex
pousse à
[Musique]
le gouvernement va donc présenter
mercredi le projet de loi immigration un
texte qui doit allier fermeté humanité
c'est de faire du en même temps sur
l'immigration avec un peu de fermeté un
peu d'humanitaire alors d'abord le volet
fermeté du texte il va faciliter
l'expulsion des étrangers délinquants
avec le retour du principe de la double
peine il réduit les protections et les
recours possibles pour une personne qui
fait l'objet d'une décision d'expulsion
et puis la maîtrise du français sera
désormais obligatoire pour obtenir un
titre de séjour plus réel avec un examen
de langue pour obtenir ce titre jusque
là il fallait simplement être assidu au
cours de français pour avoir ce titre de
séjour et puis il y a le volet humanité
du texte qui doit répondre à des
objectifs économiques et des besoins en
termes d'emploi non pourvu dans certains
secteurs donc ce texte va permettre de
régulariser les personnes sans qui
travaillent dans les métiers en tension
et puis il va aussi faciliter l'accès au
marché du travail des demandeurs d'asile
et Alex ce texte il sera d'examiner
d'abord au Sénat ce sera en mars puis
après à l'Assemblée est-ce qu'il faut
obtenir une majorité c'est l'objectif de
gouvernement d'obtenir cette majorité
sur ce texte immigration mais en tout
cas pour l'instant c'est très mal parti
car à gauche on s'indigne plutôt des
mesures de durcissement du droit des
étrangers et puis du côté du
rassemblement national et de la droite
on accepte pas de régulariser les
travailleurs sans papier par exemple le
patron des républicains avec cioti
estimait vendredi dernier dans un
communiqué que ce projet de loi
immigration traduit le défaitisme de
l'État qui faut d’être capable de
maîtriser l'immigration sans accommode
et use d'un prétexte peu crédible au
regard du nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
pour opérer une régularisation massive
qui ne dit pas son nom alors
effectivement l'examen du texte va
commencer par le Sénat en mars et la
majorité des droits du Sénat il était
également opposé on va écouter le patron
du groupe LR au Sénat br
ce texte là il y a une question et une
seule pour laquelle on va l'apprécier
est-ce que il reprend le contrôle des
fruits migratoires aujourd'hui
certainement pas ce texte-là aujourd'hui
il crée des régularisations massives
avec à la fois ce titre pour les métiers
en tension tous les métiers sont en
tension et avec le rattrapage un
deuxième guichet pour notamment les
demandeurs d'asile alors face à des
parlementaires les républicains qui sont
plutôt hostiles à ce texte pour le
moment et bien le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald de Darmanin est prêt
à faire des concessions et il a dit hier
dans les colonnes du journal Le Parisien
je le cite chez les républicains
certains défendent l'idée d'instaurer
des quotas pour limiter les
régularisations discutons-en dit le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui se montre
très ouvert avant ce débat parlementaire
pour éviter un passage en force sur ce
texte avec l'utilisation du 49-3 un 49.3
qui pour l'instant semble inéluctable il
y a une quel est votre avis sur ce
projet de loi immigration qui va être
présenté mercredi dans le détail en
conseil des ministres c'est quand même
un texte qui va régulariser des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension ça ça va plutôt dans
le bon sens selon vous disons il y a
plusieurs points comme vous l'avez très
bien dit dans ce texte il y a quand même
des points qui sont profondément injuste
par rapport à la double peine ce que
vous avez dit également et par rapport à
la régularisation moi je serais
effectivement favorable à ce qu'on
régularise tous les travailleurs les
gens qui sont sur nos territoires et qui
travaillent et pas juste les métiers en
tension d'ailleurs effectivement il y en
a déjà beaucoup ça va être une forme
d'usine à gaz nous nous sommes pour la
régularisation des travailleurs mais
attention comment ça va être fait
qu'est-ce qui va être proposé parce que
moi je viens de du Canada ou il y a
justement où le gouvernement a priori a
l'air de s'inspirer mais il prend
toujours qu'une un petit bout de la
lorgnette en quelque sorte puisque ce
qu'il faut faire très attention c'est
est-ce que c'est ces titres de séjour
seront fermés c'est-à-dire que vous ne
pourrez travailler que pour l'employeur
pour lequel il y a un métier en tension
parce que ça juste de mettre de donner
un pouvoir disproportionné de la part de
l'employeur sur son salarié parce qu'il
va lui dire si tu fais pas ci si tu fais
pas ça c'est non seulement c'est pas je
te licencie c'est tu quittes le pays
vous imaginez quand même le pouvoir que
ça donne à l'employeur par rapport à son
salarié c'est disproportionné donc il
faut permettre dans ce cas-là quand on
régularise les gens pour des métiers en
tension l'ordi aussi que au bout il y a
également la possibilité de rester sur
le territoire de manière permanente avec
un titre de séjour complet c'est pas
juste vous venez pour faire un travail
pendant un an et deux ans et vous partez
il faut aussi qu'il y ait un chemin qui
permette ensuite de permettre de
s'intégrer pleinement dans la société
française et ça je ne pas l'impression
que ça c'est dans le texte pour le
moment on attendra de voir le texte dans
le détail par rapport à ça alors parlons
de l'exemple canadien qui est
effectivement souvent cité en matière
d'immigration le modèle canadien et bien
il sélectionne une immigration qualifiée
en fonction de besoin économiques est-ce
que ce modèle là selon vous il
fonctionne et ce qu'il peut être
appliqué à la France alors vraiment oui
il fonctionne pour le Canada ce qu'il
faut savoir et ça c'est peu su par
rapport au nombre de personnes qui sont
reçus aussi parce que moi je suis pas
assez par ce processus au Canada je l'ai
fait au complet il faut savoir que le
Canada reçoit quand même 500000
immigrants par an rapporté à la
population française ça serait 850 000
300000 donc c'est ce que je dis quand on
regarde un système il faut regarder dans
son entièreté donc déjà ça voudrait dire
que la France accueille trois fois plus
d'immigrés et ensuite il faut aussi voir
que le la catégorie économique même pour
nous et qu'une partie des personnes qui
viennent dans notre pays la plupart du
temps ce sont des étudiants c'est-à-dire
pratiquement un tiers ce sont des
étudiants internationaux ça participe
aussi au rayonnement la plupart du temps
le retourne dans leur pays ça participe
aussi au rayonnement de notre pays de
pouvoir former des personnes qui
retournent dans leur pays qui sont
attachés à notre pays et je pense que ça
il faut également le favoriser et l'une
des choses qui n'est pas pris en compte
également c'est que le parcours au
Canada est facilement compréhensible tra
c'est le même pour tous vous accédez à
ce qu'on appelle une résidence
permanente assez facilement et ensuite
vous avez un accès à la citoyenneté
simplifié au bout de seulement trois ans
après avoir votre l'équivalent du titre
de séjour c'est pas c'est pas le cas en
France ce qu'il faut c'est favoriser ces
dispositions là et surtout axé sur les
politiques d'intégration puisque le
Canada a également des politiques
pro-intégration ce qui est insuffisant
et j'ai l'impression ce qui est
complètement absent du texte qui va nous
être proposé dernière question sur
notamment le volet fermeté de ce texte
et sur l'expulsion des étrangers est-ce
qu'on a un problème en France quand on
voit que chaque année moins de 10% des
décisions d'expulsion des étrangers sont
réellement exécutés alors déjà il faut
revoir effectivement toutes ces choses
là mais comme je vous ai dit il y a des
choses qui ne sont pas acceptables et
moi je pense qu'il n'est pas acceptable
c'est par rapport à la double peine
d'ailleurs la personne qui a mis fin
c'est une personne de droite c'était
Nicolas Sarkozy qui trouvait quand il
était ministre de l'Intérieur
pourtant je me partage pas beaucoup de
choses avec Nicolas Sarkozy qui trouvait
profondément cela profondément injuste
et c'est profondément injuste parce que
vous allez déraciner des gens qui
souvent en leur proche également je
pense pas que ça favorise aussi
l'intégration des personnes des fois de
leur famille qui sont présentes sur le
territoire donc je pense que c'est une
mesure démagogique qui touche déjà très
peu de monde et qui a un impact sur
beaucoup d'autres personnes merci Alex à
tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure on
parlera réforme des retraites
donc on va parler du Parti socialiste il
y a une chanterelle puisque les
socialistes étaient réunis à Marseille
ce week-end pour leur 80ème congrès qui
a commencé dans la division pour
finalement terminer dans l'Union alors
comment s'est passé le week-end on va
voir ça avant d'en parler avec vous à
Marseille où on retrouve les hauts
pluriel bonjour Léo merci d'être avec
nous président et directeur éditorial du
Journal La Marseillaise et vous avez
évidemment suivi ce congrès comment ça
s'est passé
ça s'est passé mieux que ça n'avait
commencé parce que les socialistes ont
fini par recoller les morceaux on
s'attendait à un congrès de déchirement
et ils sont finalement parvenus à une
nouvelle synthèse avec les personnes qui
se sont opposées qui sont désormais dans
la même direction et ça me ça me faisait
envie de demander au sénateur
chanterelles si Olivier fort dans ce
dispositif ne se retrouve pas finalement
pieds et point liés
que Léo restait avec nous évidemment
vous êtes soulagé oui tout à fait oui
mais en même temps je vais vous dire
pour être tout à fait honnête j'ai fait
plusieurs congrès socialistes ça fait
partie de la culture socialiste le débat
on négocie sur beaucoup de choses on
négocie sur des virgules souvent dans
nos émotions ou autre donc ça fait
partie de la culture des négociations de
virgule
on connaît pas les résultats de l'autre
avec des divisions bon vous avez eu peur
à un moment que le Parti socialiste ne
s'en sort pas bah oui on peut toujours
craindre effectivement la division moi
je suis très content en tout cas qu'il y
a eu un esprit de responsabilité par
rapport au climat social dans lequel
nous sommes et que nous avons évoqué je
pense qu'on a un besoin on a besoin
d'être à la hauteur et d'être
responsable et effectivement là le les
membres du Parti socialiste ont été
responsables et je salue ça et nous
partons justement au combat renforcer et
avec un collectif avec un pacte de
gouvernance entre nous ou qui va
permettre une délibération et une prise
de décision collective c'est une très
bonne chose et je pense qu'au contraire
pour répondre à votre question Monsieur
Olivier Faure et renforcé puisque
l'accord de la Nupe en quelque sorte
parce que le point de clivage le plus
important c'est par rapport à la mupes
ou non UPS bah je pense que en tout cas
la décision de la nupeste de d'être dans
la nupesse est renforcer à partir du
moment où 80% de nos conseils nationales
et favorable à être dans la nup sauf que
là vous avez la moitié des militants
socialistes qui disent attention on veut
pas de la ligne d'Olivier fort et vous
savez très bien que ça porte en grande
partie sur l'accord avec la nuque alors
après non parce que il y a juste une
seule des textes d'orientation qui était
vraiment en continue s'ils ont fait 20
les autres ne sont pas d'ailleurs il va
y avoir un test très très intéressant
puisque il va y avoir une élection dans
l'Ariège où il y avait eu face aux
candidats de la nups qui est les filles
une personne qui était justement
dissidente et qui était soutenu par
entre certaines personnes qui
soutiennent monsieur meilleur Rossignol
et je peux vous dire que nous la
direction en tout cas a décidé qu'elle
soutiendrait à nouveau la personne
sortante qui était les filles en
concordant avec l'accord de l'anus donc
en fait ça sera le bon test pour voir si
justement tout le monde suit bien cette
ligne et je peux vous dire que ça serait
le cas puisque
à titre d'information meilleur Rossignol
n'avait pas l'air de s'y opposer bien au
contraire donc ça clarifie les choses au
contraire je pense que ça renforce la
ligne
qui était soutenu par Caroline
donc là vous dites à Carole Delga c'est
le test il faut pas qu'il y ait de
candidat d'ici
qu'on ait de candidats dissidence parce
que les candidats décidant ça fait
gagner l'extrême droite donc en fait si
on est responsable par rapport à la
situation du pays justement il ne faut
pas de candidats dissident il faut un
rassemblement de la gauche rassemblement
de la gauche qui a été validé qui plus
est hier lors des résultats des
élections législatives partielles
puisque Bertrand petit qui était déjà le
candidat de gauche à un score renforcé
puisqu'il a fait encore un score plus
important et nous avons un nouveau
parlementaire qui a été également élu et
qui plus est il y a l’extrême droite et
ça je m'en félicite également qui ont
perdu un siège donc ça valide la
stratégie d'accord qui a été établie les
Français souhaitent que nous soyons unis
qui plus est dans la situation sociale
dans laquelle est notre pays on va en
parler avec Léo mais juste est-ce que
quand même ça Olivier Faure ne va pas
devoir changer un petit peu sa stratégie
est-ce qu'il va pouvoir faire cette
gouvernance du Parti socialiste comme il
a fait la précédente en fait peut-être
ça c'est pas mais le Parti socialiste a
toujours fonctionné de manière
collégiale puisque nous avons justement
une forme de de mécanisme parlementaire
la manière de monter organisé le Parti
socialiste puisque nous sommes nous
avons le Conseil national qui est le
Parlement du parti où beaucoup de choses
se décident justement à ce niveau là
donc en fait ça ne change pas ça ne
change rien à ce niveau là il y aura des
discussions il y aura des échanges mais
sur l'essentiel bien évidemment nous
sommes tous socialistes nous sommes
d'accord
de la part des militants socialistes qui
disent attention alors certes où il y a
l'accord mais il faut que le PS puisse
exister au sein de cet accord oui bien
sûr mais bien évidemment tout le monde
souhaite que nous exions au sein de cet
accord mais nous existons
législatives ça est-ce que ça repassera
encore là on n'est pas dans ce cadre-là
on n'est pas à nouveau face à une
dissolution bien évidemment il faudra
rediscuter en fonction des résultats qui
ont eu lieu sur un accord plus global si
jamais nous repartons en élection lors
d'une dissolution effectivement vous
avez une autre question
oui justement c'est sur les moyens pour
le Parti socialiste de revenir à une
place centrale à gauche il y en a été
beaucoup question dans les échanges lors
de ce congrès mais concrètement
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour votre
invité notamment là il était question
des élections partielles mais on pense
aussi aux élections européennes est-ce
que le Parti socialiste doit mener une
liste
alors oui effectivement et après on
verra jusqu'à quel cadre de
rassemblement aussi à partir des
socialistes nous sommes en capacité de
faire une liste qui rassemble aussi le
plus possible mais à partir de nos
idéaux socialistes puisque nous sommes
aussi un parti européen mais quand on
est européen justement nous ne pouvons
pas nous satisfaire de l'Europe telle
qu'elle fonctionne qui favorise
justement
l'ultralibéralisme ça n'est pas une
Europe de Gauche socialiste qui défend
nos valeurs donc il faut aussi avoir
confiance de ça et quand on est
socialiste qu'on veut c'est avant tout
d'avoir une Europe justement qui soit
plus politique pour pouvoir mettre en
place des politiques d'harmonisation
fiscale des politiques d'harmonisation
sociale pas de la concurrence d'État en
état pas de concurrence du tout ce
contre tous c'est la solidarité qui doit
primer donc en fait c'est comme toujours
il faut poser un socle des idées un
projet et seul qui veulent y adhérer il
y a derrière et nous rejoignent mais je
pense qu'il est important aussi de
défendre ce projet et de travailler
justement sur le fond parce que on a
parlé là de
peut-être querelle interne du PS mais
moi quand j'ai vu les propositions il
n'y a rien qui nous différencie
honnêtement c'est sûr c'est sûr vraiment
la marge c'était par rapport à l'accord
de la nups et encore comme je vous ai
dit c'était qu'une partie qui était
opposée donc en fait il y a pas grand
chose qui nous divise mais je pense que
les socialistes doit également
travailler à faire une proposition une
vision de société pour la proposer
ensuite à nos compatriotes sur les
européennes parce que ça c'est quand
même alors ce que ce que vous nous dites
c'est que
une liste de rassemblements de la nuque
mais qui doit être porté par le PS ou ça
peut être porté par la France insoumise
moi ce que je considère c'est qu'il faut
poser sur la table nos propositions qui
pour nous quelle est notre projet et sur
lequel nous nous sommes intransigeants
en quelque sorte que nous avec
[Musique]
une campagne commune mais je pense que
ça peut être difficile et toute façon je
vais vous dire l'élection européenne est
une élection au mode de scrutin très
différent c'est une élection
proportionnelle c'est à dire que les
différentes sensibilités du pays ont la
possibilité d'être représenté à travers
cette élection donc à l'élection
proportionnelle on a aussi une
proposition une offre politique qui peut
être différente on a la chance justement
dans notre diversité de pouvoir déjà
être représenté grâce à ce mode de
scrutin donc ça différencie les choses
ça permet d'avoir des listes différentes
mais d'avoir après ensuite un socle donc
il faut une liste socialiste parce que
OL plus fort quand vous étiez dans vos
jours de déchirement il a proposé à
Nicolas meilleur Rossignol de porter la
liste européenne est-ce que c'est bien
le signal qu'il veut une tête de liste
socialiste pour les européennes oui
quelque part c'est ce signal là en
partie qui a été mais attention quand je
vous dis on lance aussi des négociations
faut pas fermer tout de suite toute
discussion si les autres nous
partenaires nous disent effectivement
nous sommes favorables à ça nous sommes
d'accord avec ça pourquoi le refuser
pourquoi pas
dire pourriez-vous ranger derrière la
France insoumise c'est ça qu'on comprend
pas où est-ce que vous dites on peut
trouver un accord mais c'est la France
insoumise qui est derrière moi je pars
du principe qu'il faut poser nos
propositions nos valeurs regardez s'il y
a des possibilités s'il n'y en a pas
effectivement parce que ça sert à ça les
élections c'est de trancher en
différents entre différentes lignes et
comme ça on aura une offre qui qui sera
devant les Français que les Français
pourront décider en conscience Léo
est-ce que vous avez une autre question
oui sur la question brûlante des
retraites que vous avez un petit peu
évoquées dans vos réponses précédemment
on a de nouveau un parti socialiste qui
est dans la rue est-ce que après avoir
recoller les morceaux entre vous vous
pensez pouvoir recoller les morceaux
avec le mouvement social qui ont le sait
vous avez beaucoup reproché la loi
travail
oui absolument je crois que justement ce
qui a été opéré et la rupture qui a
opéré Olivier fort avec ce qu'on appelle
le social libéralisme et clair et net
alors cet accord en fait partie et au
moins l'avantage que ça a eu et si on
peut sortir de ce congrès avec un
intérêt c'est que désormais il y a plus
aucune ambiguïté que le Parti socialiste
est au sein de la gauche est au centre
des mouvements sociaux et ça je crois
que c'est déterminant et que c'est
décisif justement pour l'avenir de notre
pays il n'y a plus ambigu d'ambiguïté
sur le fait que notre partie est
effectivement au coeur de la gauche
est-ce que ça a pas un peu affaibli le
PSC derniers jours est-ce qu'il n'a pas
un peu perdu sa culture de gouvernement
non il n'y a pas de justement je pense
que la culture du gouvernement elle est
utile mais pour assurer un vrai projet
de gauche parce que nous à travers cette
culture de gouvernement nous savons les
freins qu'il y a quelles sont les
batailles à mener pour réussir parce
qu'il suffit pas malheureusement d'être
au gouvernement pour réussir à faire en
sorte que nos notre projet soit appliqué
il y a des puissances il y a des
puissances économiques il y a des
puissances financières qui sont contre
nous et il faut en avoir et nous on en a
conscience parce qu'on a exécé le
pouvoir mais par contre il faut
l'exercer sur un projet authentique auto
authentiquement de gauche et de
transformation de notre pays il y a on a
parlé des européennes mais il y a
d'autres élections avant les européennes
ce sont les sénateurs là selon vous
quelle doit être la stratégie du Parti
socialiste vous avez le plus gros groupe
de gauche au Sénat loin devant les
autres est-ce que vous dites là le PS
doit être moteur et doit avoir ses
propres candidats ses propres listes ou
est-ce que vous dites non mais
finalement il faut peut-être des
candidats de la nuque une élection très
particulière parce que c'est un collège
électoral d'élus et quand on regarde le
collège électoral bien évidemment le
Parti socialiste est dominant donc il
sera moteur et il est moteur pour
permettre éventuellement aussi des
listes d'union mais ça c'est au cas par
cas c'est en fonction de chaque
département en fonction des rapports de
force dans chaque département donc ça va
se négocier circonscription par
circonscription mais bien évidemment le
le socialiste sera la force motrice de
l'Union je l'espère au sein de de cette
élection sénatoriale tous les
socialistes et sénateurs socialistes
sortants qui souhaitent se représenter
doivent être investis ça fait partie des
lignes pour vous absolument il faut que
tous les sortants et sortants soient
investis et d'ailleurs il y a pas de il
y a pas de débat par rapport à ça nous
sommes totalement d'accord sur le fait
qu'il faut donner le temps pour
permettre justement d'avoir une force
qui ne permettra peut-être d'avoir
encore plus de parlementaires de gauche
on va remercier Léo qui était avec nous
Léo votre une c'est du cyclisme le grand
prix cycliste la Marseillaise
la première épreuve au calendrier
cycliste de l'UCI et nous avons le
plaisir et l'honneur de l'organisme
c'est un américain qui a gagné pour la
première fois c'était à la Une de La
Marseillaise merci beaucoup les au
purgate d'avoir été avec nous merci à
une chanterelle d'avoir été notre invité
on